here's what y equals sine X looks like
I'm gonna draw the two cycles there you
go that's good enough for me okay I'm
going to stick straight over B right
because I think that's some hair boring
you're just going to turn that upside
down right so all of these are these
hills become troughs and all the trucks
become hills so that's fine what about
this one
I'm one of your drawer because remember
how I just described this one right hey
what kind of function is sine it's not
just any function it's an odd function
and for all the functions these two
things are the same are they not okay so
in fact any odd function what does that
mean geometrically if you flip an odd
function upside down that's the same as
taking the odd function and flipping it
left to right
does that make sense you can think about
this guy as well he's annoying function
as well all right
now let's put on to the visit this graph
what's the absolute value of sine X look
like I'm just going to put it right on
top what would you like me to do with it
yeah all these negative parts they're
gonna flip up up there so you're gonna
get this guy this is the same but then
this comes up like that right so what I
just thought is why is the absolute
value of sine of X okay now it's tough
to get a little more interesting right
let's have a look at the next one when
you play an absolute value just to the X
[Music]
this guy it's a go look like I think
about what happened when we did this
with that parabola over there okay first
thing we can notice is that just like
over here here right everything over
here is fine it's just like what it was
before because the absolute value of
those positive things still those
positive things so still gonna look
handy-dandy identical okay but then what
happens do you know what happened here
how would you how would you believe
describe this to someone who can't look
at this picture if I already had the mic
inside then this is just yeah it's a
reflection across the y-axis right so
this is just gonna give us a reflection
across the y-axis that's not bad I'm not
used to drawing sine codes in that
direction so it's okay hey good what is
this this is the sine of the absolute
value of X just before t1 can we quickly
because the most fun one is why I went
straight to this one oh the absolute
value of y equals sine X this is gonna
be fun
all right quickly let's just draw it
from negative 2 pi to 2 pi I want to
call your mind back to this you might
want to ask you this and what did it
mean put a negative there what happens
to it doesn't exist right so look at all
these negative bits right those parts of
the graph they're going to use useless
to me okay
however all the positive bits he's a
positive bit and here's another positive
bit they were a K yeah they're okay to
this but that's only one half right do
you remember what happened we do you
you're gonna get up reflection
you're gonna get well not quite because
these are not vertical are they right so
you're gonna get these kinds of now just
think as you pack up right of course it
has to be that because look where's the
absolute value it's on the Y's it's a
vertical thing that's why you get
vertical symmetry that does that make
sense and this you get horizontal
symmetry because the absolute value is
on the X does it make sense okay